can you say that our series changing the
game highlights extraordinary women
making a difference now and for future
Generations you could say during Black
History Month we're focusing on black
entrepreneurs and creators this morning
we've got to introduce you to Aza Reyes
Bellamy she's the founder and CEO of
blondery that's a bakery that
specializes in blondies which are like
brownies except they're lighter and
Azaria says and better when she's doing
it Bellamy is a trained pastry chef who
worked in some of the top kitchens
around the world she found it hard to
grow her career in the fine dining
industry so she said you know what I'm
going to start my own Bellamy started
selling her baked goods online in 2017.
customers can now buy them at her Bakery
in Peekskill New York and around the
world on her website azarez Bellamy
joins us look at I love your storefront
thanks
why did you decide you were working with
some of the top chefs in the country
Thomas Keller per se French Laundry I
know all those places yes and you said I
want to do this on my own why well well
I hit a glass ceiling I think that fine
dining in a hole is really good it's
kind of like the military you learn like
the skills the techniques and then you
kind of want to be creative and I wasn't
able to be creative there
so you started in your home Kitchen in
Brooklyn oh no in California in
California yeah yeah
so uh but just so you started selling
Bondies online back in 2018 you went
from making two thousand dollars yes
2018 to 200 000 in two years yeah that's
a big jump yeah that is big thank you
and I read over half a million
um and yeah like we went over second we
did over half a million in sales last
year okay
other than they taste really good I want
to try them in a second what do you
think the secret is to that growth a
good product a good product talking
about it but what do you think makes
yours a good product what what is
different the best ingredients European
butter we use guitar chocolate Barona
chocolate King Arthur flour and we have
a beautiful space as well I think that
that matters my mom always says he took
it in a nasty kitchen you're a nasty
cook so she said that yes it does matter
Tony you could wait for us man
presentation we don't have a lot of time
we have a lot of food here that's the
pecan and salted caramel that's what
started delicious so
um what is your advice to someone who is
sitting at home that might be working
under an umbrella and thinking about
taking that leap that leap of faith that
most people are scared to do what would
you tell them if you want to take the
island you have to burn the boats
that that's important like burn all the
bridges you can so you want to take the
island you have to I'm just tell them
that yes I think it's important it's
like because you don't the plan B is
what's gonna mess you up for your future
okay now you don't have a plan B that is
not a 10 layer cake that is an 11 layer
cake 11 ish probably more okay all right
I mean what goes in what thought process
goes into creating something like that I
just wanted to create something super
decadent and I did it during the
pandemic on Instagram live and people
loved it we raffled it off and it
raffled off for like 500 so I was like
oh I could probably sell this for maybe
half the price so it is 250 and it's
double two cake chocolate buttercream
vanilla butter cream salted caramel
ganache toasted pecans and then we have
one without nuts as well are there many
black pastry chefs who do what you do I
mean just in the business in general no
yeah I mean there's tons of black pastry
chefs but not at the scale I would say
that I'm doing it and and I hope that
there becomes more so I have a YouTube
channel where I'm sharing like how to
ship perishables it has over 40 000
views
um how did you learn how to do this was
your mom a good girl how long was the
process and how long ago process how do
you get this good
um it took me 10 years to refine the
pecan and salted caramel Blondie recipe
oh wow um but you get good by mastering
you do it over and over and over and
over until you get it right yeah yeah
she got it right
amazing thank you guys oh my goodness
that's a smaller version of Jasmine
their cake oh thank you I love when when
we said it's in Peak Skill you go it's
just an hour away yes just an hour away
from Grand Central because that does
seem that seems so far to me no it's
closer than Beacon and it's a community
of brown and black people that's what I
love about Peekskill the most is when I
first got there I was like oh my gosh
this is a community of people who look
like me and then the mayor is a black
woman Mary Vivian and before that it was
a black man and I just was like so
supported the community is so supportive
in Peak school I thought I was just
going to do retail just to see what it's
like but
um and then like shut it down but we
can't do that they wanted us there this
is clearly a passion for you clearly yes
and my team I have a team too and they
all are very diligent at their work and
I appreciate that as a rest I I
apologize Bravo lack of professionalism
because I lost Focus after eating this
this is amazing thank you for joining us
thank you so much we'll be right back
this right here oh this right here
because sometimes you taste something
sweet and it's overwhelming